what do you know about the sierra
program
reckless mystery man you guys send in
when you can officially send anyone else
the great man
i'm sorry i didn't bring you again from
the homeland i mean how they say a
that sounds so like a non-canadian
saying that i have ruffles all dressed
chips ryan you are such a canadian right
now
congratulations on this movie this is
one of the best action movies i've ever
seen all due to your performance and the
russos who are just a magical magical
combination i wanted to saying that of
course i wanted to ask you i know you
said that you had no idea what you were
signing up for so if your expectation
level was that it was going to be like
here yeah
where was it give me a scale it's like
there like higher than that yeah like
right go a little higher a little higher
okay you know down a little bit okay
right there it was about there okay so
it wasn't like that no i didn't know
that was an option it's an option i
thought it stopped no no no can you sort
of describe sort of the level of it
because i know you talked a little bit
about how you there was one fight scene
between you and chris where he sort of
walked on set and said what's
choreography got it and you said you're
up all night studying it was uh you know
it took a village i had a
incredible stunt team special effects
wizards you know a lot of people you
know make the gray man giving everybody
else credit give yourself a little bit
how intense
was this sort of getting into it for you
i mean it's such a different thing than
we've seen you do yeah i always wanted
to make an action movie so like i i
couldn't complain you know this was like
but this was extreme you know i think by
most action movie standards this is
extreme because this has nine action set
pieces and most have like half of that
yeah so even it was a lot for me of
course i've never done it but even it
made me feel better because like the
russos were like this is a lot
this is a lot of action it's a lot for
even though they've been doing it for
the last 10 years so that made me feel
better so does it make you want to do
more because you typically also not
really been a franchise person but i
know that's kind of been put out there
that that's going to happen so is that
something that now you go it's like an
adrenaline rush i want more yeah it's
more fun than standing around and
talking you know it's fun it's more fun
to do it it's more fun to watch it
it's it's definitely more fun what was
fun was watching your one-liners i think
towards the end of the movie i was like
leaning forward when i was anticipating
one
for fans of the nice guys who love your
irreverence doing action and comedy sort
of how did you find those moments when
you're memorizing all this choreography
and then you have to deliver those
one-liners what's sort of the essence of
it it's always weird when you have to
ignore what's funny about a scene you
know in dramas that you just have to
ignore what's funny you know and it
feels weird because because things are
funny you know and and so it was nice
just to not have to do that it felt more
natural it felt
like more realistic in a lot of ways you
know because
i think when you meet people that have
tough jobs they often like you know you
kind of gotta laugh to keep from crying
you know
but also
it just reminded me of those 80s 90s
action movies that i grew up watching
you know and that was sort of part of
why i loved them is that they were they
were fun that's kind of what it reminded
me of and as as i'm dressed like a human
barbie
can you give me a little taste of how
much is it going to subvert our
expectations because i feel like what we
think it is is not going to be what it
is
that's
i think margot said it best she said uh
you know that whatever you think it is
it is it is not that and um
i would never argue with barbie what
barbie says goes i gotta leave it at
that right yeah
uh so good to see a fellow canadian
thank you nice do i get to take the
chips oh no no no
no you can't have to you want to make an
omelet
you got to kill some people
you must be loyal what gave it away the
trash dash it's just it leans lloyd
[Music]
i'm going to start with you chris okay
you get to say these great one-liners
these great like words like ballsy which
is in the trailer you also get to call
ryan kendall did you sort of make these
up on the fly were these the russo
brothers and how delicious was it to
play this kind of a douchebag slim pant
slinking around kind of character i
guess some of those things were on the
fly some of those were the russos just
screaming things out behind the monitors
um
look it's nice it's nice to play someone
who's
uh kind of so universally
loathed but in terms of the character
himself i don't think he sees himself as
a bad guy they never do actually
exactly i mean i don't see myself as a
bad person
you know what i mean
well the russo brothers did say you're
closer to lloyd than cap how did you
feel about that
i'm going to look at that through the
lens of expected i mean maybe i'm just
that good of an actor they said it in
the sense that he's a lot has a lot more
panache maybe like a lot more sass oh
good okay yeah so how do you feel about
that yeah sure sure
maybe it's just that cap is so void of
sass that that lloyd is the next closest
thing to someone who has flavor
um for you
i'm not going to ask you an action
question i'm going to ask you i'm going
to ask you an action question i asked
ryan this because ryan said his
expectations were sort of shattered in
terms of how difficult this was going to
be i know you probably already shot bond
when you shot these scenes
so for you what i loved was in the in
the genes scenes
they you went for it like there was no
holding back there was like a head slam
the whole audience reacted to it so were
your expectations how was it in terms of
what you expected it to be i mean
definitely i got a little bit of
training and an idea of what it was
going to be like getting myself into an
action film but for bond was just very
brief this was another level of
complexity and discipline and commitment
i mean this was months of training and
not just
not only the choreographies and
rehearsing with ryan and danush but also
for me was like training with all these
weapons and getting familiar with them
and
it was
a lot and i heard they're notorious for
saying can we reshoot that can we
reshoot that oh i wish it would have
been a question i think it was just like
yeah yeah
of course you don't look happy
i mean it was uh it's you got to be very
patient when this happens because it you
take two weeks to shoot something and
all of a sudden it's like that doesn't
work
you need to do it again lloyd has a very
specific fighting style very different
from what you've done in the past was
that an intentional thing and sort of
how did you get into sort of the
physicality of what he is because like i
said from the way he walked i was
thinking about lloyd last night after i
saw the film he sticks with you and
that's what a great villain does great
yeah um
yeah i mean i mean he's he's uh he's
violent he's uh visceral there's
something about him this little wild
but he's trained you know so so it's
still going to be from a foundation of
understanding a structured form of
fighting it's not a superhero there's
only so much he can accomplish um but
but it's more about
will
than it is ability and we talked about
this woman's versatility you went from
this to playing marilyn monroe can you
give us like a little bit of a teaser of
what we call
actually maryland was like three years
ago it was okay so the flip then how was
it going from and can you give us a
little bit of a tease of what we can
expect another netflix project i think
this movie is going to throw people you
know um in the way it's been told i
think it's not a
traditional biopic it's not literal is
not conventional it's not even
chronological it's just it's more like
an experience and the audiences will
the hope is that they will feel what it
was like to be her wow that was a great
explanation that remember everything you
just said that was great i was like damn
i want to see this move yeah mine's
perfect every grade a wet team from here
to rachel
vying for the prestige of killing the
infamous year six
congratulations on the film you're both
incredible in it i heard you say before
that you wanted a role where you were
either just sitting or standing i love
it when comments that we make it on the
first day of the junkies start coming
back to us
you also said that you love this
character because she doesn't care about
what people think yeah she's
unapologetic as somebody that cares too
much about what people think tell me how
liberating i'm the same i'm the same and
yeah it was really liberating it started
on a great note i i went into the studio
on day one and i said let's figure out
this hair i want it to look like she got
a haircut two years ago
and then has been doing it herself in
the bathroom keeping up with it and we
achieved that
and there was a joke about your haircut
in the film was that as a result because
yes right the comment about your hair so
lloyd says i i liked you better when you
had the haircut that didn't make you
look like a
[Laughter]
delightful
[Music]
it's the perfect haircut for her because
she looks like a politician
and she kind of is she is
ambiguous she's morally she's morally
flexible
and we never quite know where she lies
on any any topic until the end when she
finally reveals her hand she's very much
playing the long game
hugely affected though like i think you
get more done than a lot of characters
in this movie you do get a lot done and
multifaceted too and
for you i heard that you said you said
that you your character likes to think
he's morally ambiguous as well but he
likes to think that he's better than
everybody else so i love that you're
grinning
how do you challenge the spirit of denny
coming back
how do you get into character when you
have to believe that you're better than
anybody else because i'm assuming you're
not like that no you just kind of it's
like taking a holiday from the british
just kind of you flush all of the
politeness out of your system and then
just kind of see what's left in the dark
sticky shadowy corners that you kind of
banish in real life and i think that's
what an audience relishes in a bad guy
because i think everyone has those
corners and in polite society we all
kind of sit on them and know that we can
never go there and so having characters
that can go there for you that have no
moral restraints they can kind of really
lean into
just how creepy they can be with
anadamas on your behalf you know is is a
real thrill ride um and so it's just
it's leaning into all the things that
you would never do
um and just seeing how far that goes
creatively you know wow wow i'm as a
canadian i kind of understand the
reserve nature and the not wanting to
like to be a little all you do is turn
off the canadian and see what's left
did you surprise yourselves
every day i surprised myself when i when
i was told to yell at chris and they
said just go go as far as you can and i
don't even know if that's the take
that's in the film but when it happened
like i was frothing at the mouth
and i smacked the table with both my
hands and then as soon as we cut i was
like ow it really hurts yeah um for both
of you because obviously they've already
talked about prequels sequels i really
feel this film is so excellent that it
is so deserving of a whole universe
so i'm wondering for each of you what
would you like to explore in your
characters
in either fashion a prequel or a sequel
also i would kind of like a prequel to
see the origin of these super villains
i want to say i want to start the film
with us being really nice a really nice
trio of friends and then what happened
to make us all so dark being actual good
human beings somehow got
corrupted yeah into these things what
happened yeah no i take that i think
that the joy of how ambiguous all these
characters are how complex they all are
morally is that they can kind of go
any direction you want to take them so
it's fun that we have that set up i can
kill anybody
maybe not anybody it's nikki novak from
rotten tomatoes and the russo brothers
are asking me questions so go ahead
what about what why let's not start yet
so you said that uh one of my favorite
action movies you said it's one of your
favorite action songs so and you but you
also said that's you're not in our demo
like this is yeah like it's not
typically the kind of genre i go for
what i liked is the relentlessness of it
just because it didn't end it didn't
stop it just went from thing to thing
and even your connector shots between
scenes you had the camera moving really
fast and moving like across cities and
above and kinetic energy all throughout
the kinetic energy so maybe i can ask
you yes how you get that pace because
pace is the word that i walked away
thinking about we wanted a propulsive
film i mean it's excessive in that
regard when we read the novel uh it had
excessive action in it we loved it it
felt like a challenge we're like this is
the most action i've ever seen in a book
ever and there's a lot of inventive set
pieces all built around a great
character who you're rooting for because
none of this works unless you have a
character that you know vibrates warmth
and that you know you want to see
succeed which is why ryan was so perfect
for this character but um you know the
intention was to make you forget to eat
your popcorn or put your phone down and
just you know pay attention uh to the
movie because it starts and it doesn't
let you go till it's over but for as
strange as it is it may sound the the
process the road to getting to something
relentless is the opposite of relentless
you know it's like it it's a very
arduous process it involves a lot of
trial and error around our part
for months and months and months to get
something to the point where it's it's
worth that yeah like the train the train
sequence for example there were shots it
was going so fast that i was trying as
an audience to keep up with it yeah
which is a good thing yeah so when you
say it has to be slowed down like also
the attention to detail you can sort of
like walk me through how you sort of
because this to me is even better than
anything that i saw in marvel like it's
another level oh that was great
again joe and i we our entire process of
filmmakers started with our experience
as film fans and our favorite movies
were the kind of movies that we could
watch over and over and over again and
the reason why you can watch a movie
over and over and over again is because
of the the level of detail yeah some
movies
yeah they're woven in a way where
there's layers happening in every scene
and you can sometimes in one pass you're
you're sort of living with this layer
and other passes you're living on other
layers and that's that that's the type
of film experience that we've always
loved so we try to design our movies in
a very similar way so it is uh you know
we're happy that um you and hopefully
others can find some pleasure speaking
of lairs ryan gosling i've heard you
call them spectacular i concur
he is
unbelievable in this and this is really
his first big outing as an action star
that's right and then you also said that
you don't normally see two big movie
stars like one who's willing to play the
villain so can you tell me as filmmakers
because i wish a fly in the wall i wish
i could have been there when you saw the
two of them on the lens for the first
time how palpable that energy was well
it's incredible i mean it's a cinematic
tradition to get you know the movie star
showdown you know and it's it's rare to
find somebody like chris who is in a
comfortable enough place in their career
that they want to take risks like that
and play a complete sociopath a very
unlikable character and so it's hard to
create this kind of movie a showdown
movie of this scale we are like little
kids the little kids and us when we saw
them both on set reminded us of heat and
face off and all the you know sort of
you know the classic movies where you
know movie stars would go at each other
and we designed the film specifically to
be that so we're very lucky you know
fortunate to get um um two
extremely talented can you conceptualize
what the film would look like if they
had swapped roles
well it's interesting i mean that'll
take a while to unpack
ryan has an incredibly quirky sense of
humor that really informs the gray man
he's an existential character who's an
existential crisis you know he's he's
never been a a you know free person he's
you know he was uh
grew up under an abusive father went to
prison grew up under the you know
spend his adulthood under the abuse of
cia
um and and so that character needed this
levity
as a way to deal with the stress that he
was going through and that was really
unique to who ryan is and lloyd is this
very showy
charismatic superficial a-hole that you
know you know likes to take over a room
when he walks into it and you know uh um
chris uh
has the ability to just like exude
charisma on screen so i have a hard time
imagining them swapping roles but uh
because they're both so perfectly suited
for what they did in the movie but it
would be fun to make them try yeah it
would be sequel world rick denucci he
brings such a different acrobatic energy
than they're they're sort of like the
powerhouses in a sense they have very
different fighting styles but can you
talk about when he came to seven sort of
he the experience and
grace that he brought yes yeah danish is
he's an incredible screen presence uh
yeah and he look at he comes out
comes out of a very different tradition
in india and he is as good as anybody
gets coming out of that tradition um the
fact that we were able to work with him
on that role on that role for this film
is like an incredible gift but yeah
that's part of the fun of the film is
that especially when you're crafting
this many action sequences and you have
this large of an ensemble you're looking
for
what kind of unique flavor energy voice
each character can bring to the table
that helps us
fashion a fight or a conflict moment of
action around a different idea or tone
and danush brought an incredibly fresh
tone into the movie and uh we've noticed
so far we've been at a few screenings
audiences really respond strongly to
what he's done yeah who decided to call
for chris's character to call ryan's
character kendall whose idea was that
you know we try to unpack it yeah
it might have even been evans
possible i don't know
sometimes the ideas flow so fast it's
like who knows weirdly it predated
ryan's commitment to the role so stop
yes we like to think that we willed that
into existence they'll have something
they really want
what's your gut it's gonna be my funeral
you're going to next i wanted to ask you
what is it like working with this legend
she's already worked with the russo
brothers tarantino now she's working
with steele spielberg
well no we just did we did a q a for a
screening the other night and they asked
me a question and the guy was too far
away from me i didn't quite hear what he
asked me so i just thought i'll answer
anything and
i assumed because they usually ask you
the first question is what made you
accept this project and i said i've been
wanting to work with julia butter since
i was a teenager
my favorite answer to anything ever that
is adorable i love it and i might have
seen that q and a and i might have heard
that you should get a screenwriter
credit young lady for this phone because
improvised a line that the russo
brothers were like yes let's put that in
so tell me a little bit about that that
was amazing we weren't even really i
don't even know if we were filming my
coverage but it wasn't a close-up we had
already done my close-up um
and now we were on maybe chris or a
wide shot and um i was about to turn and
leave and i turned back and i said kick
his ass and ryan went
he kind of looked at everyone like oh
right i gotta stay in it
because i wasn't the kind of i mean i
don't think i was the kind of person to
usually do that so um i came back out
and uh they said all right we're gonna
do your close-up again because we really
liked that and i was so excited i mean i
rattled ryan yeah what
what
i can't believe it so i was stoked and i
i was
honestly every time i watch it now i'm
gonna be like yes no i saw you doing
like a little mini impression of the
russo brothers sort of can you do an
impression of how they give direction
um
i'm better at doing billions
when you talk like billy you gotta bring
it to the depths of your being and kind
of
kind of
talk through your breath but also when
you do the w's you gotta well
win
thank you that's my wife and my daughter
both are only every day for putting the
h and when and why it's amazing never
change it
my favorite okay now i got to ask you a
very pressing question yes you're
de-aged in this film first of all how is
it shooting that and sort of seeing
yourself but also there's a very key
prop in the film watermelon bubblicious
do you remember watermelon bubblicious
and
yeah your thoughts on sort of that well
my era was more into double bubble
to tell you the truth so this was uh
for me bubblicious was like a new thing
but uh
yeah bubbalicious was like yeah that was
something they put in there and i was
like yeah that's pretty funny and the dh
and all that like filming that and sort
of seeing yourself and watching the film
now do you like when you're when you you
they sort of de-aged i said i guess in
cg and post-production
oh for the reason yeah for the first
time
like physically when you're shooting
that do you sort of like mimic sort of
like maybe go back to your old older
roles or look at it or think about it as
you're filming it not really no i mean
you know the hair and makeup people just
do their thing and uh you know because
i'm in my mid-30s now
and you know when you have to go back to
21
it's uh i have memories of that so
that's not i don't have to dig too deep